[Music]
in a country like lesotho
people travel for days in search of a
covert 19 vaccine
but at the moment they are very unlikely
to get one
only 36 000 people here have been
vaccinated
including a tiny fraction of those
considered
most vulnerable to infection and they
live on a continent
where just 1.5 percent have been
protected
yet donations from the world's
wealthiest nations
are now trickling in today the uk said
it would supply
800 000 doses to kenya as part of a
tranche
of 9 million jabs we won't be safe in
the uk until everyone is safe around the
world but it's also in our direct
interest
in terms of opening up the economy
opening up international travel and
making sure we don't see
fifth sixth waves of this virus or its
variance
moral interest and self-interest at work
as boris johnson and
kenyan president uhuru kenyatta talk
trade
investment and vaccines in the garden at
checkers
the prime minister promised to send 400
000
jabs this week but kenya
like the rest of africa needs tens of
millions of vaccines
the world health organization's kovacs
facility
ground to a halt last month leaving
officials
in an impossible spot the head of
vaccinations in kenya telling us
his program was running on fumes as of
today
in kenya we have received 1.733 million
doses
of astrazeneca and we have actually
vaccinated about 1.7 million people
so today even as the uk was making the
announcement
we had less than 30 000 doses and and
and yet the demand is very very high
well that is a nerve-wracking way to run
a national vaccination campaign
yes oh it's nerve-wracking of course
it's it's experience but
it's from circumstances that we learn a
lot
in africa they've learned they have to
start making vaccines
in africa otherwise wealthier countries
buy up the stock and here in south
africa
two factories will now start to make
these vaccines in fact
one has already started and what's
probably the best way
to overturn these global inequities
it's said that you have to have a
tragedy first
you know for things to really happen but
i think you know in a nutshell that's
why we need more capacity
it's a start but health officials need
1.5 billion doses
to inoculate 60 of the african
population
a task and a challenge that will take
years
john sparks sky news